stranger things fans listen up now that
will byers is confirmed to be gay i see
some discrepancy online thinking that
it's a forced agenda or narrative he's
always been gay he was heavily hinted at
in season one and they made it
especially clear in season two it's my
fault you don't like girls
secondly if you missed our major
announcement we've recently partnered
with heavy spoilers in screen crush to
combine our merch zone to one nerd
kingdom and yeah stranger things fans we
got real rejects gear you can rock to
represent being a citizen of this great
reject nation but more importantly our
special shirts are stranger things
inspired greg and john is dustin and
steve scoops ahoy when we were doing our
reaction to the finale and eleven put on
those pizza glasses i said t-shirt
someone making that shirt so we made it
one more important we got a limited run
shirt when we all learned that vecna is
one and we learn to not trust ones on
netflix we put one and one together
squitter game
something anyway it's a limited run so
you can go to shop zero edition.com and
get yourself some awesome apparel thank
you guys will's always been gay accepted